e obrigado por meu filho veio pra ficar
convosco algumas das questões que eu
considero importantes e uma delas é
provocar a nossa sala e vou pensar com
uma pequena história eu vou ligar seu
nome ao plenário
é o meu nariz estava em meus da festa
das duas festas nos ajudaram o santos
soma também na volta né em que eu numa
das festas dez países junto à china e
motivo não tinha vaga estou deus e pelo
desafio é esse
se na pressa utilizei do lado oposto o
dra
ficaram com todos os casos vocês já
viram o filme gravado em estágio tem
quiser ficar em silêncio sepulcral isso
aí você já pensa em duas partes onde na
maioria desafio aos quilos podem ficar
cada vez mais um desafio
agora além dos carros e nos bairros
podem ficar com os meus aviões ou são
alguém na china
cheia de grupos e os lutaram e um dentro
ficou toda arranhada outro ato com as
lutas ganhar e como estava completamente
por fora o que eu posso fazer quando é
que eu posso entregar de buscar o
mercado interno caso não quero chutar o
carro não quero ficar e um dos bairros
como é que posso jogar
eu também não quero
o que eu posso fazer para entregar os
ouvidos e um continua fiel então o que
era um homem só quero encontrar um
sacana de manter o ativo é isto é o que
nos acontece muitas vezes na nossa vida
a alguém que nos empurra para a rotina
ea nossa vida é como china tinha proteus
com vários tendões tem piranhas tem uma
série de dificuldades da vida também
tenham filhos também tem coisas boas que
temos que aproveitar essas coisas aqui
condições produziram nesta história
a primeira é essa força narrativa em
diversas obras e sei o quanto a
aproveitar essa sala e não nexo é que
colhem os frutos que o tempo está a
condicionar os projetos quando nós
muitas vezes na nossa vida somos
obrigados pelo projeto
então tem que aproveitar esse projeto é
o melhor possível e não obrigar os
planos pré e vai sentir
foi nessa alternativa que tem contrato
com o propósito de sua vida e provoca
pessoal para as poder mais competência
faz por ter as primeiras consultas para
ter não posso ir para a china vai mesmo
ea dourados é sagrado e eles têm a ver
com o que deve muitas vezes com aquilo
que nós temos um planejamento da câmera
nós muitas vezes somos nós estamos em
fase e precisamos de pensar no futuro e
precisamos ponderar as nossas campanhas
eu vou dar dois exemplos é que prevenção
brincar tem uma militar e do calçado que
é o director geral da fábrica de calçado
que vai do trecho sendo
o procurou para sendo o diretor geral da
fábrica calção nas férias de um eu ia
para a fábrica passavam as férias bons e
passaram dois meses pelas próximas que
ela trabalhava na fábrica com os seus
funcionários e aprendendo tudo que tinha
que aprender para poder falar com elas o
cartola para sensibilizar também porque
ia dizer e como resolver as situações
outro amigo foi o próprio que pedro
silva tony a a sua casa venceu quando
acabar o curso vou estar dez anos a
trabalhar para outras pessoas e depois
fazer um bom problema nós e vou aprender
muito sobre finanças que vou aprender
muito sobre marketing e comercial esteve
três anos a trabalhar na área financeira
e vamos trabalhar na área comercial da
empresa e sax e orientar para os últimos
a ter um gol certo a ferramenta e eu fui
se usaria a grande final que não é muito
frequente cair tal quem queria trabalhar
nas férias no havaí no bairro trabalhar
nunca deve contaminar o trabalho aí é no
vídeo ao gol quando já havia continuar
trabalhei com o pintor e trabalhei das
obras
eu vou dizer muito rapidamente que as
obras todos os que deram lições de
trânsito e foram ótimos para melhor
organizar para saber onde as curvas nas
obras de algumas empresas estão
dominaria o primeiro gol foi quando eu a
vi nem lembrava que eu queria frazão 30
minutos com márcio araújo vai ficar a
questão quem quiser se há nada oficial
não sou festivo - o que fez aqui para
zonas
queria saber o que a gente queria
trabalhar e é parte do crescimento e ao
centrão é só star wars são pessoas
comuns que algumas delas ainda conserva
como amigo
são 15 que a vida não é fácil pra mim e
deus mas é criar o ações muito excluído
porque eu não fui para o festivo das
obras que é que eu tinha vindo bons eu
fui porque queria saber o que é que nós
na nossa vida tem esperança que a
votação sabendo que estou a inventar
vários dias são assunto né almoço
tradicional - nós temos que ir lá e
fazer um estágio onde quer que seja é
aproveitar ao máximo e fazer um grande
sinal é que o conseguimos por a alergia
e nós não gostou de ter quase sempre
contente em ter essas pequenas nem
resguardar tarefas melhor para
demonstrarmos a nossa competência
este fator foi essencial no foi
absolutamente essencial
o mais extraordinário em entre os
primeiros projetos que o motivo nada
combinado foram na área da construção
civil foi certificar empresas coisas tão
sensível e aquilo que ela é muito
interessante é que eu falava a linguagem
dos empregados dos três que também
falava a linguagem de outras são de três
dias aos seus jogadores na hora porque
passar por todos os lados
o fato tem passado desde o ano mas até
quase permitiu muitas vezes pelo contato
muito interessante com as duas irmãs que
fazer coisas que muitas vezes eram
difíceis eu sabia o estado está querendo
saber as dificuldades e isso faz toda a
diferença está na nossa vida senão
apanharia e nove gols que não vou sequer
ousar
vamos tanto é para saber que está em 90
por mim por lei
a vida não é uma linha reta vamos com
certeza ter algumas situações
onde há dificuldades vamos esperar vamos
dizer não
isto é para mim e depois volto a ele na
final é pra mim é isso mesmo que eu
quero porque em todo e em toda esta
experiência aproveitando o vá ao grêmio
é que eles ainda consultoria por
eleitoral foi o quinto curso disseram
claramente que gostariam de estar aqui o
estágio
eu achei tão a consultoria mas não só me
apaixonei como faz aí há mais trabalho a
fazer e isso é muito importante porque
porque nós vamos andar primeiro momento
vamos procurar fazer aquilo que o estado
neste aspecto é um em que ocorre o
desafio pois faço é um claro desafio ao
voltar para o meu desafio trabalho acho
que vocês pensem é que é um grito que é
um ipp cura e por outro desafio na minha
vida que kuip burra o epi cuba porque o
primeiro cuca faz lembrar os nossos
antepassados mais vagas é uma questão
que atualmente está no nosso
entendimento mostrá lo
continuamos e evoluímos muito em termos
tecnológicos mas continuamos a ser muito
falado e naquilo que é fundamental na
nossa vila
nas nossas eleições primárias nos nossos
dicionários
esse livro continuam iguais às de mais
atrás ou quase 3,8 e nessa certeza eu
tento e como trabalha com muitas
tecnologias como trabalho com muita
gente áreas tecnologias
já já organizados no congresso eu gosto
do documentário tenta destas mas pra não
esquecer da importância das emoções a
importância do domínio das competências
básicas
nesse sentido o olhar que é saber que
qualquer pessoa nossa volta nos podem
ser a única coisa que podemos aprender
piano é fundamental termos união podemos
ter opiniões divergentes na união é
fundamental essa decisão e vier um
jogador que faz a diferença na nossa
vida vai lá lado da ambição da equipe e
não tem por onde vão conseguir alcançar
ponte não conseguiu alcançar alguns e
outros vão ficar no papel e todos
aqueles que não conseguiram alcançar são
aprendizagens para chegar mais longe que
os vários aspectos
o outro lá é o amor a paixão como disso
é uma paixão e fé mãe enquanto corta o
bairro - leiam também estamos
apaixonados somos apaixonados em várias
áreas da nossa vida
mas o fato precisamos do passado da
paixão para outra fazendo aquilo que
gostamos de marquinhos fazer para que
seja porque a contrair acho o nosso amor
por aquilo que fazemos e mais forte
porque eles prometeram
passar por aquilo que eu gostaria é que
todos voltassem e fizessem comigo e
perfura pode ser eu vou lá eu gosto e pe
pi pb agora façam isso
onze crianças escrito a volta por cima
ao som do sucesso mais uma vez um grande
nível para vocês meus caros